hi thank you for having me
my name is Tom and I will tell you about
a very decent walk with Alessandro
chiesa Michel folds and Nikolas Cunha
and this is the tacular spatial
isolation implies zero knowledge even in
a quantum world and what I will actually
show you is how to construct zero
knowledge in my P style systems so zero
knowledge proof that'll sound against
entangled porous okay so let me start by
thank you little bit about the problem
and why I find it exciting so one thing
I want to say tomorrow told me that this
should have as little as possible
preliminaries in complexity theory or a
cryptography so in fact you can say it
suffices to have zero knowledge about
complexity and couldn't resist the pun
okay so what is the problem so you had
this nice smart watch I will settle for
a laptop we have a week computational
device and say that this device gets two
graphs and we want to know whether these
two graphs are isomorphic or not now
this is generally a hard problem and so
this Poe device might want to use the
help of some either someone more
knowledgeable who might have generated
the Gulf's or someone is just more
powerful like a cloud server provider
for example so basically a good book
would be just to give the typical and
people from which we give the bijection
between these two graphs and and
everything is nice and well however this
reveals a lot of information about these
two graphs and in particular it does not
preserve the privacy of the poro
so what zero knowledge both give us
chili is a way of proving a statement
for example these two graphs are
isomorphic without revealing anything
about these two graphs at all
so in particular we cannot give this
coloring here that we see okay and legal
knowledge so this is they don't know
that it was introduced by both Bassam
Cali and Morocco and this is a very
influential and powerful notion both top
of 80 complexity theory and it is
actually even being used in practice
for example even in deployed systems
such as for crypto currencies such as
the cache and for blockchain technology
so he's both it has the privilege of
being both interesting theoretically and
also relevant to parties so what do we
know about their knowledge books so we
know from a lot of go drive McCauley and
it goes on that we can have the
knowledge books for all of NB but under
kappa graphic assumptions now we might
want to ask can we get this information
theoretically can we get the knowledge
without any assumption any Kappa graphic
assumption so in the setting of like
interactive proofs which we know this is
essentially impossible and we really
have to make this cryptographic
assumption however not all is lost and
we do have another model which is called
multiple interactive books MIT which
I'll just talk about and as we mentioned
the original motivation for this model
was we want to be able to get zero
knowledge without making any sort of
assumptions whatsoever okay so what is
this model essentially we ask yourself
what happen if we have two porters for
example rather than one now if this pool
can communicate and then we can actually
view them as just one unit and so we
gain nothing so what we do is we
especially isolate them such that we can
be convinced that the strategies are
completely independent and under this
scenario we notice we know that the
spatial isolation this in the classical
world it means that these two powers are
acting completely independent like they
the strategies are completely
uncorrelated and under this uncorrelated
strategies we can prove zero knowledge
not only for any language in NP but for
the much larger complexity class of next
so this is what we know for ma peas if
we think about the quantum setting when
this is no longer - of course for
example it could be the case that these
two puzzle or clouds will share an
entangled State
and then they'll if they measure it the
strategies can actually be correlated it
could be called just by a comma so what
does it mean to state so this is
captured by the MIT style model talk
about it but let me just recap it
essentially we're saying that we have
these two pools there again spatially
isolated but they do share some
entangled some entangled state between
them which can function in the most
naive way yes common and ominous but it
can also do more now we have the
question of what is the power of this
model so
you notice that what we did here has two
effects when we added this additional
so first of all the poppers are now more
powerful and secondhand so they could
use this extra power to convince the
power off
conversely verify all patient perhaps
they couldn't convince otherwise but on
the other hand this also gives them more
room to cheat so it could very well be
the case that we actually made the model
even weaker so what do we know in terms
of increasing the power we actually know
very little
we have no upper bound no reasonable
upper bound on and maybe start and it
could be that it contains even
undecidable languages and on the floor
bounds for which languages we can get
and maybe start protocols so for a long
while this was a very hard problem and
took quite a lot of time until a strong
result to thing
and indeed walk of Ito in Vedic it was
shown that the class next which is like
NP but much better is contained in MIT
style so for every language in next we
have an MIT style protocol okay so now
we we have some some sense of what MIT
style is all about let's go back to the
original motivation in which ma piece
will introduce to begin with we
introduced an M a piece of Community
Interest MIT to be able to obtain the Oh
knowledge unconditionally does this
thing still holding the m AP style
can we get with tuples or more zero
knowledge proof for a large language and
so this is the problem that we try to
answer him and I will answer is yes
Oh a bit more accurately we pulled that
for every language in Ex the existent
MEP style protocol which is perfect zero
knowledge and all of this is unlike in
the else talk this is information
theoretical we soundness holds against
unbounded bubbles so this is the what
I'm gonna show you today oh ok so first
of all an immediate question why isn't
this obvious so on one hand we know that
we have ma P in the classical setting ma
P equals next so we have even from the
BFL from the 90s walk we know that we
can get my people to correspond X on the
other end we know that we can get zero
knowledge ma piece so we have to open
all the movies for next and on the other
hand we know that we can get any
language in X we have an M ap style why
not just mix the two together and the
point is that the techniques that are
being used to get each of these results
are fundamentally different so in
particular perhaps the reason why the
Ito Vedic paper managed to get the
success of constructing MIG styles for
such a large class is because it looked
it opened the it white box the VFL
construction and said let's look at the
particular structure and in heavily-used
algebraic structure that is being you
disease in this protocol in particular
it strongly relies on low degree testing
and low degree polynomials well the way
that we actually know how to obtain zero
knowledge for a large class of
computation typically use community
techniques like commitment schemes and
and these type of techniques do not play
nicely with the techniques that are
being used to pain ma p stop what a call
to get resistance e to
entanglement and doing new things like
taking the Camaro Atkinson just encoding
them by polynomial so somehow trying to
endowed them with this algebraic
techniques ends up eliminating the zero
knowledge properties to begin with okay
so so that's fantastic
like we have no upper bound for MIP
style without the zero knowledge
assumption it could be that it is much
much larger than that all some evidence
to all shown that perhaps it is louder
however at this point we don't know if
showing this without the Oh knowledge so
we do yes I know you know but not yes
agreed but it depends on what do you
mean what you mean by getting louder
computation we can do slight and in
perhaps we can actually match that now
with the owner llege
so okay so let me tell you just a bit
yes again how how we do it so we do it
in two steps essentially so the first
step is a way of taking classical
protocols and lifting them to be
resistance to entangle strategies so
this is the way which takes a white
family of portables I will tell you
about in Sunday's are what are called
whistled with an inherent algebraic
structure and we can completely black
box way just transform them into an MEP
style and most crucially this is being
done while preserving the OL knowledge
okay so this is the first part so we
know how to push to get classical
protocols make them quantum while
preserving zero knowledge always need to
have now these algebraic type of
protocols which are also zero knowledge
essentially what we're doing we're
designing these poof systems which are
which have certain algebraic properties
and zero knowledge and then we just
leave them those via a completely
generic power line so did you know is
only if the bottom part is algebraic yes
structure yes exactly right and the next
slide will exactly characterize I give
the description of what is this magical
class of protocols that we can actually
lift let me just tell you that the first
part the lifting lemma this is like
mostly conceptual contribution in the
tentative mostly about finding like how
to put the pieces together in a way that
is delicate enough to preserve the whole
knowledge but technically very simple
and getting this algebraic type of zero
knowledge this is where we have to
really walk hard
and we have to for example introduce the
own algebraic ways of commitment schemes
and the own already some Czech water
calls and this is work things more
interesting ok so this is the strategy
and what I plan to do now is tell you in
a very high level about this spot and
then prevent this is we don't know that
it's taken from what that goal drive
being posted he hasn't ever tell you
about it later
ok so now these are the magical
algebraic see we will take other an
algebraic type of an interactive
disappear and transfer them into MIT
stuff oh so what would this lemma tell
us if we have any low-degree interactive
PCP then we can take it in a completely
black box way and transform it into an
MIT fellow with very similar parameters
so let me go and gradual explain what
other low-degree
interactive PCBs Oh so first of all PCBs
this is a rather standard modern we have
Google and verifier the poodle sends a
long poof and the very file only want to
makes a small number of queries to this
week only pop it and say three different
locations today and so little away from
coding and be witnesses that allows for
very local modification just by for
being a few bits okay this is nice and
well there is another notion introduced
by aligners in oh wait which are called
interactive PCBs and what our
interactive disappears
these are PCP circles as before only now
instead of just letting the very file
make small number of queries to verify
the Pacifica it can now also have an
introduction
Pawel so typical protocol would look
like the Hoover would send is BCP its
poof and then the verifying improver
would engage in an IP interactive force
hopefully communicating as little as
possible bits of information and this
could make us potentially and it turns
out that you can get much better
construction in particular we could have
not gotten the result that we wanted if
we only used BCPs but we rather need to
use the extra power by the way even
though this is completely looks like a
completely theoretical notions it turns
out that you can actually take this type
of interactive PCPs and compile them
into snogs and snarks so this is also
this kind of things actually being
compiled in practice it sends the proof
it is now written it can no longer
change it in any way no just making
queries and talking about the proof but
okay and now what is the additional part
so low degree so this is all about the
things that jumped here so we require
that the specific oracle is simply a low
degree polynomial so this will be global
I will view a lot of a polynomial using
the low degree extension view which
means that here we have some arbitrary
information and this would be a low
degree polynomial that encodes this so
this is a read model called rule okay
and the point is as follows
but if you have this low degree
interactivities then we can take them
and in a completely black box way
transform them into M ap style protocols
while preserving zero knowledge wise
just the first arrow I mean so let's
play this game I'm the pool I'm sending
I'm writing down a load of a polynomial
this is the PCP it is now fixed after
that the verifier Ram the Pawel
talk arbitrarily and this is like being
read completely this is a standard
communication and can also evaluate the
polynomial in several points and the
point is that instead of sending an
arbitrary BCP Oh an arbitrary vol.2 be
queried you have to knowledge then just
in yes yes more than that the way that
our lemma walks we actually need several
things that form the interactive PCP for
example we need to have verify would
make just one query which is uniformly
distributed so this we don't know how to
do and it seems possible with non
interactive PCBs so we really do have to
use this interaction not only to
construct your knowledge but also to so
it would fit to the to the framework I
will I will get just saying that if we
don't kill about preserving zero
knowledge then we can omit the low
degree requirement so we can take any IP
CP and just transform it into an MIB
style but this will not give us anything
in terms of this would completely when
zero knowledge okay so you still need
only one query
we can get I will go actually right now
so okay this is a completely classical
protocol all parties here are completely
classical and we're now gonna make it an
MEP style portal which is entangled over
okay the point is that all the pieces
are already there all we have to do is
use use them correctly and make sure
that we are constructing it in a
sufficiently simple way that zero
knowledge would actually be preserved
and not get ruined by any of the
modifications that we are doing so in a
very very high level let me just tell
you about how the hardest lifting water
call works so we're starting with this
interactive PCP this is the same as
before only smaller but we're doing some
pre-processing to it how do we do this
pre-processing we're using an idea by
colliding glass well we perform query
reduction so we use the interaction to
get the query complexity to one and we
also make sure this is being done that
this particular query is uniformly
distributed so how would this particle
how does it work so essentially we start
this possible so we have this IP CP now
we're constructing an EM ap style what
does this m AP style protocol - first of
all we toss a coin to decide which game
we'll play with probability 1/2 we would
just invoke the MIP style point versus
plane loaded retest return vidiq
actually we need a slight variant of
this which tomorrow is kind enough to
provide us with but this test we can
view it as follows an MEP spouts water
column and we think that each one of the
portals view thinks has in mind a
certain low degree polynomials list in
the owners case
and whatever fell it would ask one of
the pools for a random point and the
other pool for a random plane so this is
the quantum analog of the point versus
plane load the greatest and the beauty
of the analysis of the this theorem is
that we know that if the poles managed
to pass this test for consistency of
this point and plane then in a sense
this restricts the the set of strategies
that we can use to essentially something
which is approximately just taking the
quantum state and using it as random
coin to decide on a lot of a polynomial
according to which day the answer so
once we do this with probability 1/2
then we know that inside probability now
we can assume that they are lovely
behaving like like look up for followed
is a polynomial in which case what we do
is we emulate the the interactive
disappea here
so one prophet as before would play the
role of being look up for this
polynomial here in the IPC P and the
other one would take on the wall of this
portal now of course the lab so this is
the high level of white box of course
there are some complications and for
example for this low degree test walk we
need the particle to be symmetric and if
we use standard way the Scimitar izing
it then we can lose the or knowledge oh
we have to be careful but hopefully this
gives a high level of how this works
and now to the main part which is the
algebraic zero knowledge
Oh
so this goes as follows we want to prove
so we know that we can take any low
degree I PCP with zero knowledge and and
turn it into an M ap style which is your
knowledge so what's left to do is
actually construct these interactive
disappears which are zero knowledge
right so the previous techniques not we
can just take any existing construction
of pcbs and because it was not algebraic
to begin with and we can endow it with
algebraic structure without destroying
the zero knowledge so where do you use
quite a few components
well the notable one this is where I
show him questions back up a result know
where the important parts are showing
new structural results about extensions
of the read model code showing an
algebraic commitment scheme and strong
theorem strong zero knowledge subject
protocol now of course I won't have time
to cover all of them so we will focus on
one water column which is getting
algebraic commitment scheme and the
reason I chose it because I think is
also it's both reasonable to do in terms
of time and
is also I think interesting on its own
outside of the without the load so yes
nothing that can play even remotely play
with in the sense that if you and you
can just so you can have like SEO
knowledge PCP and then you say okay
let's try to to to play with it like
reduce the complexity but the point is
that it has to be at the end of the day
just one query to a low degree
polynomial and the only way I can see of
getting that this is like what our
lifting paradigm it requires and the
only way that we know if doing it is
like take the PCP or Whitnall PCP and
just encode it by a lot of a polynomial
but doing this this toy is the all
knowledge so this is why okay so let me
tell you how this the bike scheme
committing scheme looks like and so
again we have a pool and the belly file
and what's going on now is we want the
portal to be able to commit to some
element they just filled element but it
would be any message and we wanted to
satisfy two conditions we wanted first
of all whatever the portal sends will
not reveal it would hide the message
this is because you get want to get this
type of they all know that so we want
not to avail our message but on the
other hand we want it to be committing
so if the portal then chooses to
convince us that this is actually
he want to be commit to this element he
can do it in an efficient way so how we
do it
the idea is quite simple what we do is
the poodle wants to commit to this the
Baker so he chooses a very loud think
about exponentially polynomials evaluate
on exponentially many points and a
random polynomial that if you take some
of systematic Pato think about this is
just evaluations of so the sum of all of
the terms here I'll the element which we
want to commit to so why is this
potentially good so the idea is that
exponentially many terms the nope
efficient very if I can just sum over
all of them and we'd hope so we hope
that this would suffice to hide on the
other hand we can use interaction and
use some sort of a variant of knowledge
some check in order to decommitted so
after its end this polynomial there is
an efficient polynomial efficient
interactive proof that can convince us
of the of this sum without revealing so
you can think about this like 2 to the N
exponential this is a huge yeah some
sort of
so we are not this is all these are okay
so it can be done
this requires like to do it carefully I
mean I'm not saying anything about this
protocol like because we won't have time
to cover it but I can tell you okay so
the idea is that we sent the commitment
just by providing the disappeared or the
polynomial and we performed the
committing by doing an interactive
protocol okay so now how do we do it
so this might look this is just so how
does the so I want to look at our poof
polynomial this is just I'm thinking
about this many times our polynomial and
essentially what we're sending is an
evaluation of the whole thing okay so
we're spending a lot of a polynomial
it's sum over HM is the element which we
want to commit and yes now let's see
what happens
the polynomial so this is like a PCP or
visiting cent and this is like we think
about the reed-muller code word just
devaluations all evaluations and we can
make quizzes which means that we can get
evaluations of this polynomial so let's
for a second zoom in on the market
powder HTM and we call that like our
load is a polynomial here the degrees
rather than H - there's no algebraic
structure whatsoever these are just
numbers that are being stacked in this
grid over ten so in this case we know
that summing over all of the terms you
this is something that is shouted hard
to compute so if this was the case and
if we just sent this like many many
numbers exponentially many numbers and
we'd say this is some everything
would've been peachy
however then we wouldn't have any way of
performing the committing in using an
interactive portable so let's see what
is the problem that we're facing with so
instead of just sending your view we're
sending the entire polynomial all the
valuations now the developer you want to
compute the sum of all of this thing but
you can also make Willie's heel and heel
and heel now you can ask yourself well
is this problem still hard perhaps there
is some information in the wrote the
extension some point that you can query
that would help us or perhaps not and
this actually has a strong connection to
the Allens and exhaustion and
realization framework because if you
think about it what we really want to do
here is we want to prove query
complexity lower bound well you're
allowed to make queries not only to the
input but also to its low degree
extension okay now so this is question
and when I first heard of it I said well
of course it's still hard to compute
what will all this junk that we have in
the lovely extension help us but I was
wrong
and apparently for example if we just
consider the multilinear extension then
there is single point in the turns oh
it's just the inverse of 0 1 just the
inverse of 2 so we can evaluate one
point and actually get some of the the
entire cube so this is depressing
because what we will do is our
commitment scheme although fortunately
it is the case that this is a phenomena
that happens because of multi linearity
and you can view you can actually prove
quick impress Iliyana although abounded
if you're using at least something of
quadratic length of quadratic degree
then such crazy thing cannot happen and
if you want to sum over the entire cube
you have to essentially read as many
points as the exist in the
characteristic later this is quite an
interesting one actually so okay so
um okay so I don't think I have time to
so I had in mind to show you a nice book
which actually follows the about some
videos on paradigm of using
communication complexity reductions so
well I wanted to show you
Yvette Allison Bob so there is a nice
reduction that you can do which proved
this theorem rather nicely
so just but let's conclude that we know
that if we are if you have at least the
Greek tool and we want to get it only
the sum of all the cube then we're
completely happy and and this is like a
good hiding scheme that can be for which
we have a protocol now what really
happens is that the way I will the way
we do the D committing is using some
sort of sound check portable and doing
this protocol the portal also sends us
additional information so it's not that
the pod just provides this logical
polynomial the beginning he also tells
us other things what are the things we
don't want so for example it can send us
partial sums and this way I want to know
only the value only yes this is only for
the CEO knowledge I want to be able not
not to reveal any information under the
the value that the povo wants to be
commit to and on on the way to that he
provides me with lots of information
about this polynomial which is
problematic so for example it also sends
these partial sounds so for example you
can view this is like just sending the
sum of a line and sending the sum over
some plane yes it is a big knowledge
type of subject it's subject in which
you do you mask the polynomial by taking
a linear combination with random
polynomial and it's
yes a univariate polynomial yes so and
this would correspond to this polynomial
so I gave all the evaluations this is
summing over all A's and giving you just
the first valuable and so forth
so at the end of the day now what
happens is not only we have to know that
given Google making the ability to make
will not reveal something about this sum
but rather we want that if we also know
this the value of our planes and
hypostasis then this would still not
reveal any information and also we can
take the linear combination of all the
points and so so this is me trying to
hide the individual protocol in the real
protocol we are not only committing to
one element but rather we are committing
to a polynomial I want to open just one
evaluation of this polynomial
however like this explaining of how to
do it for polynomial rather than single
elements this would into the source of
complications and this is why I try to
hide it under the rug but yes this is a
perfectly good question so I don't want
to avoid anything other than this
particular point because I committed to
a whole polynomial okay and so at the
end of the day what we have to do is
extend the Allens and ago some type of
framework in which you want to prove
query lower bounds for algorithms that
query an input and install the extension
to algorithm to get access to what we
call the Sigma late model code word
which is essentially taking the logical
extension together with all the plains
and lines that of the type that is being
in to us in some czech portable and what
we actually prove in this thing is that
you
feel given access to do this thing which
essentially all information that you can
get doing the protocol then you cannot
learn any summation of the external be
making less than by receiving less than
X term from the overall by equating them
yourself and unfortunately for this we
cannot use the elegant communication
complexity reduction and we have to use
purely algebraic techniques ok now I
want to conclude by just tracing a
couple of open questions that I find
interesting
one of them so we've got the next
contained in amap style and we do it
using polynomially many rounds now some
complexity is very fundamental thing
that I yell focus about getting as close
as possible to non interactive is
crucial so can we do this with just oh
one rounds
another question is this lifting
paradigm well we can take any
interactive PCP and lift it to an M ap
style protocol so can we do it for a
wider class of protocols other than just
interactive PCP is all for example if
you want to preserve the knowledge just
yes I do
relation for example hoc utilization so
there are techniques in this setting in
which you can reduce the complexity
reduce the complexity however they do
not cause of the whole knowledge so in
other words why is the next round and
you just instead of asking it
so even doing this type like being done
in KL when you replace each round by
Whoville and this type of poker I can
tell you about it later but they turn
out to fail for make the type of stages
that we need so this is we still don't
know how to get that we believe it
should be possible using but it some
sort of over here realization some sort
of Milan squashing but it is not exactly
entirely clear how to do it in this yes
when you're in this settings and
suddenly you can just use and this is
you can just do your typical way of
reducing the rounds
yes version of this conjecture
[Music]
yeah so not a time off in particular we
have tried even and it requires stronger
types of algebraic with complexity lower
bounds then we know currently know how
to prove okay so back to this problem
which also find very interesting is can
we take a larger trust than just low
degree interactive PCBs and lift them
and one way to do it
one strategy that was successful in the
classical literature is by trying to
abstract so all of these results are
using low-degree testing and the way
that we can only get such the only way I
know getting em a piece top what calls
fall out languages includes some sort of
algebraic machinery or testing machinery
so what we can do is for example maybe
we can see them instead of just all of
algebra maybe you can abstract it and
replace it with codes that have
potential local testability or local
decodability and one place which I find
interesting to start is can we use
tensile codes and perhaps we lie and get
take that is also done type of local
test for them and generalize it to that
for immortan get like want environment
resistant tens of code testing
okay so thank you very much so you're
saying yes that is it would take i think
longer read and so one what one can
helpful is that so we don't know upper
bounds on maybe star but now with zero
knowledge then we actually have a
simulator of the currency polynomial
time so we have additional structure so
one can hope to prove upper bounds on
zero knowledge i might be stalin in who
knows perhaps this could somehow lead to
some insight on the non zero knowledge
model
it actually contains so it's small fully
flaming and obstructing we are using
components that exist in in Ito Vedic
and the novelty is and how to maintain
zero knowledge while using them but you
can view it as a way of you know
obstructing what is being done so I will
piss me is actually an interactive PCT
so it is more of the type of BF Ellis
it's like by Nature
so if you were only talking about PCP
it's not interactive disappears then you
not only who we need a couple of things
for like eating or setting we can start
by using the interaction to reduce the
query complexity to one you cannot get
that for example for general disappears
this is why you can't just take PCP of
your choice
I'll think Tommy
[Applause]